the release have just cost three is now  just about a week away and developer  Avalanche Studios has finally shared the  hardware specs you'll need in order to  play on PC Just Cause 3 requires a  64-bit operating system you'll also need  at least a gtx 670 or an HD 7870 with  two gigs of memory in order to play to  hit the recommended specs that bumps it  up to a three gig GTX 780 or a four gig  r9 290 the full specs both minimum and  recommended follow intel core i5 2500 k  running at three point three gigahertz  and an AMD phenom 2 x6 1075 te at three  gigahertz and an nvidia geforce gtx 670  at two gigs or an AMD Radeon HD 7870 at  two gigs for the recommended specs you  one in intel core i7 3770 running at  three point four two gigahertz or an AMD  fx-8350 it or gigahertz eight gigs of  ram and an nvidia geforce gtx 780 at  three gigs or an AMD r9 290 at four gigs  Just Cause three launches on December  first for pc xbox one and ps4